-The president got booed
at the World Series
a few days after we found out
that his lawyer had butt-dialed
a reporter.
For more on this,
it's time for "A Closer Look."
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
Obviously those things
are not related.
It is a sign of how crazy
everything is right now.
On Friday we found out
that President Trump's
personal lawyer Rudy Giuliani
had accidentally butt-dialed
a reporter twice
leaving voicemails about Ukraine
and Rudy's need for cash,
which means we are officially
at the point where these guys
are confessing out of their
mouths and out of their asses.
[ Laughter ]
The next time they talk about
leaks,
remember, they mean Rudy's ass.
And then less than two days
later,
everyone had to shift from
Butt-dialgate to the news
that the leader of ISIS
had been killed
after the president cryptically
tweeted,
"Something very big
has just happened."
He tweets about a huge
intelligence
and military victory
for the United States
like a stepdad who just scored
backstage passes
to Hootie & the Blowfish.
[ Gruff voice ] Kevin, I know
you're not my biological son,
but you are about to wish you
were because something very big
has just happened.
And yet another sign of just how
much of a roller coaster
Trump's presidency has been,
in that two-day span,
he went from the low
of his personal lawyer
butt-dialing a reporter
to the high of killing the
world's most wanted terrorist,
and then that same day,
back to the low of getting booed
at the World Series.
-President Trump greeted by boos
by many
at game five of the World Series
between the Astros
and the Nationals.
-The President and First Lady
of the United States.
[ Crowd booing ]
-Now, you may think that I have
two beers right now
to celebrate Donald Trump
getting booed,
but I'm actually holding two
beers to celebrate this guy
who took a ball in the chest
last night
rather than drop his.
That guy had a better night
than the president
of the United States.
That guy right there.
That guy took a ball
to his chest
rather than drop his beers
and jumped ahead of Joe Biden
in the primary.
[ Laughter ]
But really, the best part was
just watching the joy
drain out of Trump's face as he
realized he was getting booed.
I mean, look at that.
He's like kid on Christmas who
sees a giant present
and then opens it and it's just
a box full of packing peanuts
and a Yankee candle.
What scent is this?
Damn it!
Now, again, this raid
was a major military
and intelligence victory
for the United States,
and yet, even in announcing
such a huge achievement,
Trump couldn't help but do
what he always does --
make it super weird.
-Today President Trump announced
that ISIS leader
Abu Bakr al-Baghdadi was killed
in a raid by U.S. special forces
in Northwest Syria overnight.
-I got to watch it
in the situation room.
And we watched it, uh...
so clearly.
We had absolutely perfect --
As though you were watching
a movie.
It was -- The technology there
alone is really great.
[ Laughter ]
-Honestly I would not be
surprised if to keep him busy
while they
carried out the mission,
they made him watch
an actual movie.
[ Laughter ]
[ As Trump ] It was ama--
Tom Cruise was there.
He put on his flight suit,
jumped out of the plane.
And, you know,
just let me assure you,
the whole mission strictly
followed
what they in the military call
"ghost protocol."
[ Laughter ]
-There were times when Trump
seemed much less specific
about basic facts
of what had happened
and how it was carried out.
-Which special operations teams
were involved?
-Uh, many of them. And at the
top level.
-That's the face of a man
who does not know the names
of the teams.
That is the face of a man who is
still 50/50
on whether Navy SEALs
are actual seals.
[ Laughter ]
He's not sure, but he knows --
He knows the window has closed
and it is too late for him
to ask.
[ As Trump ] So, General, to
congratulate the Navy SEALs.
what do you think, like,
a bottle of Scotch,
or maybe like a bucket of fish?
Whatever.
The scotch? Yeah, yeah.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
[ Laughter ]
-Now there might be some people
out there
thinking to themselves maybe
Trump deserves less credit
for this than the actual
military
and the intelligence officials
who carried out the mission.
And by some people,
I'm referring to specifically
to 2012 Donald Trump who tweeted
"Obama deserves much less credit
for the killing of Bin Laden.
The praise goes to
our brave military
and intelligence officers
and stop congratulating Obama
for killing Bin Laden.
The Navy SEALs
killed Bin Laden.
What amazing to me is not only
the fact
that there's an old Trump tweet
for everything,
but also how many there are.
All of his tweets should have
come with
an automatic disclaimer at the
bottom that said,
"Unless I'm president, ha-ha,
in which case, I believe
the exact opposite."
[ Cheers and applause ]
In fact, in a 2011 TV interview,
Trump even went out of his way
to insist repeatedly
that Obama should not get credit
for killing Bin Laden
because it was an easy decision.
-He killed Bin Laden.
-He didn't kill Bin Laden.
You know, he gets
so much credit for that.
Okay. Excuse me. Excuse me.
-He authorized it.
He had the guts
to make that decision.
-The military and the genius --
Excuse me. Guts?
I don't know why Obama
gets credit
for the whole Bin Laden thing.
He's sitting there.
He's got three choices --
Leave him alone,
which nobody would do.
Take him out with a missile,
or take him out
with the military.
So he said take him out
Okay. Congratulations.
I keep hearing about,
"Oh, Bin Laden."
The military did
an incredible job
and they called him
and they said, "We have him."
And he said, "Go get him."
What's he gonna say,
"Don't get him"?
And he gets all this credit.
It's a lot of crap.
-You know, if cable news
wanted a dissenting voice
to come on and criticize
2019 Donald Trump,
all they would have to do
is hire 2011 Donald Trump.
I mean, it would be
a lot of fun to watch.
-It is a tribute to the courage
of our armed forces
and to the decisiveness
of our commander in chief,
the president
of the United States.
-The military did
an incredible job.
and they called him
and they said, "We have him."
And he said, "Go get him."
What's he gonna say,
"Don't get him"?
And he gets all this credit.
It's a lot of crap.
[ Laughter ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Trump then went on to tell
a completely fabricated story
about how he was the first
person to warn of the threat
posed by Bin Laden
before anyone else even knew
who Bin Laden was, a claim
that has no basis in reality.
-You know, if you read my book,
there was a book just before
the World Trade Center
came down.
And I don't get any credit
for this, but that's okay.
I never do.
I said, "There is somebody
named Osama Bin Laden.
You'd better kill him
or take him out."
Something to that effect.
"He's big trouble."
-He doesn't even have the energy
to lie convincingly.
You know someone is lying
when even they say something
to that effect.
It's like if your wife
confronted you about
where you've been all night,
and you said,
"Honey, I was at the office,
or something to that effect."
[ Laughter ]
Trump also --
[ Cheers and applause ]
Trump also kept up his ongoing
war with Democrats in Congress
when he told reporters he had
chosen not to notify
House Speaker Nancy Pelosi
about the raid
because he didn't want
the operation to leak.
-And have you notified the
congressional leaders about
this, Pelosi?
-We've notified some.
Others are being notified now
as I speak.
We were going to notify them
last night,
but we decided not to do that
because Washington leaks
like I've never seen before.
-Did you inform Speaker Pelosi
ahead of time?
-No, I didn't. I didn't do it.
I didn't do that.
I wanted to make sure
this was kept secret.
-I'm sorry, but it seems weird
to criticize Pelosi for leaks
considering every time your
lawyer farts, he FaceTimes CNN.
[ Laughter ]
[ As Giuliani ]
Anderson! What do you want?!
[ Normal voice ]
You called us.
[ As Giuliani ] Oh, Rudy!
This is why you can't eat chili!
[ Laughter ]
Now the timing
of Rudy's butt-dial
is not ideal for Trump.
Because today Democrats
announced they will hold a vote
on an impeachment resolution
on Thursday.
So as the impeachment inquiry
ramps up,
this is who Democrats
are dealing with.
-Rudolph Giuliani, there is
no elegant way to put this,
but he butt-dialed
an NBC News reporter last week
inadvertently leaving
a voicemail message
that no one
was supposed to hear.
-Do you know how hard you have
to sit down on a cellphone
to unlock it
and then call someone?
I mean,
what was Rudy doing anyway?
[ Laughter ]
"What are you doing, Rudy?"
"Oh, I'm just returning
some calls."
And Rudy butt-dialed the
reporter not once, but twice.
And on one of those voicemails,
he can be heard discussing
a mysterious plan
involving Bahrain and a need
for hundreds of thousands
of dollars in cash.
-Tomorrow I got to get you
to get on Bahrain.
You gotta call.
-Yeah. Hold on.
-Got to call Robert again
tomorrow.
Is Robert around?
-Rob? He's in Turkey.
-The problem is we need some
money.
We need a few hundred thousand.
-It used to be that if you
were in law enforcement
and you wanted to catch someone
talking about a mysterious plan
involving Bahrain and hundreds
of thousands of dollars,
you need an undercover cop
and a surveillance van.
Now all you need to do
is sit around
and wait for Rudy Giuliani's
phone
to slide down between his chair
and his butt crack.
[ Laughter ]
"He's talking about the cash,
and now he's making a hand-off,
and, uh, what's -- I'm sorry.
There's a sound.
It's, um --
I think it's someone
letting the air
out of a balloon?
[ Laughter ]
-As Democrats intensify
their impeachment inquiry
and prepare for a Thursday vote,
this is who they're up against.
So if you're a member
of Congress who gets a call
from Rudy Giuliani,
just remember,
you might hear
a lot of evidence,
but you also might hear...
-A lot of crap.
-This has been "A Closer Look.".
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪